Facebook announcing a new digital currency
and aims to make it as easy to send money around the world
as it is to send a photo.
Facebook wants to befriend your wallet.
We are fully committed to working with regulators
here and around the world.
David Marcus is a Facebook executive who was called to testify
in two congressional hearings this week,
after releasing a white paper last month for a new digital currency.
Satoshi Nakamoto is the pseudonym of a mysterious software developer
who released a paper describing the cryptocurrency Bitcoin.
on an obscure mailing list in 2008,
and then disappeared two years later.
So we are discussing a currency
controlled by an undemocratically selected coalition
of largely massive corporations.
This is not Silicon Valley.
Facebook now wants to control the money supply.
Like a toddler who has gotten his hands on a book of matches
What could possibly go wrong?
Satoshi Nakamoto created a decentralized software network
that no government agency
has the authority to regulate or control.
We've got the Treasury, the Federal Reserve,
the SEC, the FDIC, the OCC,
CFPB, the NCUA, the CFTC,
the FHFA.
Which of all of these regulators
would have a piece
of creating the rules of the road?
Do you believe currency is a public good?
Congresswoman, I believe that sovereign currencies are sovereign.
Do you believe Libra should be a public good?
Congresswoman again,
we will work with all of the regulators and
and address all concerns,
and the regulators will definitely...
I'll take that as a no?
I should take that as a no?
It is not for me to decide Congresswoman.
Okay, I'll take that as a no.
In the end, Congress has a great deal of power.
But one of the most important differences between
Facebook's Libra and Bitcoin
is that it can never make Satoshi Nakamoto sit in that chair.
It takes a breathtaking amount of arrogance,
a breathtaking amount of arrogance to look at that track record
and think, you know what...